so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ten nine eight side distribution six
five four three two
[Music]
one
[Music]
good evening it's friday october 2nd
and on your screen is a live view of
falcon 9 awaiting its 9 43 p.m eastern
time launch
from cape canaveral air force station in
florida
my name is jesse anderson and i'm a lead
manufacturing engineer here at spacex
welcome to our webcast coverage for gps
3 space vehicle 4
for the space force the u.s space force
satellites provide
mission critical global access
persistence
and awareness for national security
and have become vital to our global
community and world economy
the global positioning system or gps
payload is one that you're probably
familiar with
it will provide a diverse range of
navigation and timing services for both
civil and
military purposes today's payload will
join 31
operational gps satellites already on
orbit and will help serve over 4 billion
users worldwide
let's take a closer look at the vehicle
that will launch the gps 3 satellite
now on your screen is a view of space
launch complex 40 with falcon 9 which is
our two-stage
liquid fueled launch vehicle getting
ready for launch
falcon 9 stands approximately 229
feet or 70 meters tall which is slightly
taller than a 21-story building
that bottom two-thirds of the vehicle is
a brand new first stage
and its job is to accelerate the vehicle
all the way to the edge of space
where we'll drop off the second stage
carrying the payload
tonight we will be attempting to recover
the first stage on our drone ship
just read the instructions tonight which
is currently about
350 nautical miles northeast of our
launch site you can see that on your
screen
what's really exciting is that this
specific
booster is planned to support the gps
3-5 mission next year
which will be the first time the u.s
space force has agreed to fly a flight
proven booster
so we're all really excited about that
about two and a half minutes into flight
the first and second stage will separate
and the second stage will ignite its
merlin vacuum or
mvac engine to carry the gps satellite
to a highly elliptical orbit separation
from second stage will occur
approximately 20
000 kilometers above earth and then the
satellite will will perform burns to
raise
its position to enter a circular mio or
medium earth orbit
and reach an apogee of approximately
approximately
20 200 kilometers above earth
inside of that structure that you see
right there in front of you on your
screen
is the gps3 satellite and that structure
is what we call the payload fairing
which is about 17 feet in diameter or 5
meters in diameter and about 43 feet
or 13 meters tall this payload fairing
protects the satellite from aerodynamic
heating
loads and contamination during ascent
once we're in the vacuum of space we no
longer need this protection so we will
jettison the fairing halves as the
second stage continues with the
satellite to its targeted drop-off orbit
the fairing halves that we are using
today are new and we'll be attempting to
recover them using our
recovery ships that you see on your
screen mistreat
and mischief and now because weather
plays a major role in the recovery
efforts about
two minutes before fairing halves the
fairing halves are set to land
the team will check in to see if it is
safe to make a catch attempt
and this is because weather can impact
the sea states for mystery mischief
but it can also affect the fairing's
altitude position and speed which could
change how the fairing halves fall back
to earth
now that large trusted structure next to
falcon 9 and
on your screen it's to the left of
falcon 9 there that is what we call the
transporter erector or te the te is used
to roll out
falcon 9 to the launch pad and it raises
it to the vertical launch position
and also routes power fluids and
communication to both the rocket and the
satellite
now let's get a status update on the
vehicle
good evening from spacex headquarters in
hawthorne california
i'm john inspector falcon 9 principal
integration engineer
now the launch vehicle and satellite
vehicle teams are ready for launch
as we approach the t-minus nine minute
mark to liftoff
now this is our third gps three launch
and all three have been from space
launch complex
40. the spacecraft team performed their
functional checkouts of the gps
satellite earlier today
and the falcon 9 team began their final
checks at t-minus two hours
most recently we completed the poll to
proceed with propellant load and launch
this was at t minus 38 minutes and all
parties were go
so the team at cape canaveral began
loading propellant at t minus 35 minutes
we used the same propellants on both the
first and second stages
the second stage is primarily a short
version of a first stage
that's one of the many reliability
features in the falcon design
our fuel is a refined form of kerosene
known as rp1
our oxidizer is super chill liquid
oxygen called locks
we chill it well below the boiling point
so we can load more
onto the booster as well as avoid the
need to continue topping it off to make
up for losses
due to propellant boil off now currently
the
second stage that you can see on the
screen just above that black inner stage
cylinder
that second stage is fully loaded with
the rp1 kerosene fuel
the first stage is going to continue
loading kerosene fuel until t
minus six minutes liquid oxygen is
loading onto both the first and second
stages right now
we're also loading helium into storage
vessels on the first and
second stages we take this cold helium
and run it through heat exchangers on
the merlin engines
that heats the helium up and that hot
helium is used to fill the empty volume
in the tanks
created when the engine pumps are
pulling propellant out of the stage
by heating the helium it expands the
volume that it
occupies and that increases its
efficiency
now at seven minutes we're going to open
the pre-valves before between the first
stage engines and the propellant tanks
we'll begin the engine chill in sequence
this is where we cool the turbo pumps to
avoid thermal shocks
when we start the pumps at t minus two
seconds to light the merlin engines
we're inside seven minutes and we've
heard the call that engine chill has
begun right on time
on the gps spacecraft the team has
transitioned the gps spacecraft to
internal battery power that finished at
about t minus 13 and a half minutes
that is their last major activity that's
required before launch
on the range the eastern range is ready
to support they are green and go
and the good news on the weather while
we've been dodging thick clouds that may
have forced a launch scrub
for the moment the weather officer
believes that the cloud layers are thin
enough
and may just get past us that we aren't
going
to have an issue we'll listen but six
minutes and 19 seconds to go
we should be able to get there now if we
do have to call a hold on today's launch
we have a backup opportunity tomorrow
liftoff would be a few minutes earlier
at 9 39 pm eastern time but right now
all systems continue to be go for a lift
off just past 43 minutes after the hour
as we mentioned earlier today's mission
is for the u.s space force launching the
gps-3 space vehicle for
payload now we'll hear from the air
force's lieutenant colonel margaret
sullivan and lockheed martin's tonya
ladwig
for more information on tonight's
payload
[Music]
sweet every day
today everyone has gps technology in
their pocket
25 years of space-based position
navigation and
timing supporting the entire world gps
touches the lives of everyday people
all the time
it's changed the way we work it's
changed the way we play with over 4
billion users worldwide
we're already preparing for the next
generation of gps
satellites thirteen three follow-on
contract and we're inserting greater
technology for greater capability
[Music]
the brand new united states space force
owns
the premier asset position navigate
hiding service to everyone
we're just over four minutes from
liftoff everything continues to be go
for launch
right now the clamp arms around the
second stage are opening
we are about to retract the strongback
away from the falcon 9.
we're going to move it about two degrees
away you can see on the monitor the arms
are open
we've pressurized the stages uh as we
as part of that and right now we are
moving away like i said
about two degrees away at liftoff
hydraulics will then pull the strong
back to a position that's 45 degrees
away from the rocket to make sure we're
clear for liftoff
now first stage fuel loading did
complete on time at t minus six minutes
we're waiting to hear first stage locks
load complete at t
minus three and then a minute later
locks loading on second stage
strong back lower has been announced
close out for flight so the strongback
is in position
ready to support launch at one minute
before liftoff you're going to hear the
announcement falcon 9 is in startup that
means the rocket's
own internal computers are on
autonomously controlling
the falcon 9 countdown
coming up on three minutes waiting to
hear how lox loading is going
stage one lux loaders goes out and we've
got close out of the first stage locks
load
now on top of the falcon 9 the gps3
space vehicle continues to be go
they have done their last activity
getting on internal power they're
waiting for liftoff now
good news falcon 9 team gps team we're
working no issues on the rocket
and the weather continues to be green
and good for launch
i call out you just heard m1d engines
are fully chilled in for flight
that means when we get uh spinning the
turbo pumps at t minus two seconds
uh the temperatures are cold enough so
that we won't
turn any of that liquid oxygen into
gaseous oxygen
which would be bad to pull through the
pumps now as a reminder as we come up on
two minutes if we don't launch today
we have a backup opportunity tomorrow
liftoff time would be scheduled
at 9 39 pm eastern time
stage 2 lock slowly close up
we're inside two minutes closing out
liquid oxygen on the second stage
we're now going to begin draining the
liquid oxygen down the strongback away
from the second stage
back down through the lines making sure
that everything is clear
out of that strongback for liftoff
that's what's going to be creating the
white clouds that you can see
around the rocket right now coming off
the strongback as we vent the gaseous
oxygen that's very cold
and it meets the warm humid florida air
and you get the big light clouds of
condensation that's normal for us
next major activity again at t minus one
minute we'll be in startup
first and second stages will also begin
to pressurize for launch
falcon 9 is in startup
there's a call out we've gone into
startup
next up spacex launch director gives the
final go for launch
this is the mission director go for
launch
we're coming up at t minus 30 seconds
everything
looking good all systems are go for
launch of falcon 9
with the gps3 space vehicle number four
stay twenty minutes fifteen seconds
ten nine eight seven
six five four
three
and we have an abort all agencies stand
by
as you can see right now it's t minus
two seconds we did not get to t minus
zero
we heard the call out of an abort
they're currently
safing the vehicle we're going to be
listening just here if we can get some
more information
john inspector back again you can see
the clock is reset to t
minus 15. that doesn't mean that we are
going to attempt another launch we are
going to scrub for tonight because we'll
be out of the window
however that's where the clock resets to
as they begin safing the vehicle
right now the team is busy making sure
that the automated sequences to safe the
launch vehicle
are underway we did not get down to t0
we did not try to launch we had the
abort as you saw on the screen at about
t
minus two seconds which is just the
start as we get into the engine ignition
sequence
now for falcon 9 lighting uh rocket
engines and then
shutting them down is fairly normal we
do this in texas when we test the stages
we also do this when we static fire the
falcon 9 on the launch pad
as we did with this rocket several days
ago
so going through the sequence to save
the vehicle is fairly standard for the
launch team
we're hoping that we may get an
announcement from the launch director a
little bit later over the countdown net
[Music]
you
so
john esper again back here at the
webcast desk in spacex headquarters
halton california if you're just joining
us you can see two minus 15 minutes
mission director's clear to scrub
following today's report
uh stand by for discussion on recycle
we've just heard the spacex launch
director on the countdown net
announce what we talked about earlier we
have a scrub for the evening
if you are with us we got down to about
t minus two seconds approximately we
haven't seen the actual shutdown time
we were just starting the engine
ignition sequence when we had a hold
we then began safing we did not get into
lighting all
nine of the merlin rocket engines
right now we're waiting to hear if
there's anybody else coming up on the
countdown net but it doesn't appear so
so we did scrub or we did hold the
countdown
at about t minus two seconds because our
window only lasted 15 minutes tonight
and we don't know how to quickly
solve the issue and try to recycle
launch
plus we had already loaded propellant
and we can't hold once we do that
we are scrubbed for the night as you
heard just a moment ago
from the spacex launch director on the
countdown net
we're going to hold on for just a little
bit more see if we can bring you any
other information
right now we're still waiting to find
out whether it was a ground or a flight
vehicle issue
that caused us to hold the countdown and
scrub for the night
you
you
john esper with you again from the
webcast desk here at spacex headquarters
in hawthorne california
well we had uh we dodged the weather
tonight we got down to almost t-zero but
we held at approximately t-minus two
seconds
as we were getting ready to ignite the
nine merlin 1d engines that would then
take us to lift off and out in space
we are in a safing process right now
fairly standard for the falcon 9 we've
run this on the vehicle many times those
who have maybe seen static fires with us
before
the vehicle is safe team is working
through to make sure that they get all
the steps complete
we did hear from the launch director
just reiterating
that because of the hold at t minus two
seconds uh
we and the space force mission director
have gone ahead and scrubbed the launch
for the evening
now right now the vehicle is being saved
doesn't appear to be any issues on the
launch pad but that does end our launch
opportunity for tonight
our elect next launch opportunity is
saturday tomorrow
at 9 39 pm eastern daylight time
now we're not sure yet if we're going to
recycle and try to launch in about 24
hours the team's going to have to work
through the
issues figure out whether or not we have
to go inspect anything on the launch pad
how quickly we can do that but we still
have the possibility that we'll be
protecting of trying to be able to go 24
hours from now
so whenever we do get another chance to
launch falcon 9 with gps3 satellite
vehicle 4
hopefully you'll join us again at that
next attempt
but until then thanks for joining us
today and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you